olivia pratt corbell should have been
safe behind this door
what was refuge
now a vital piece of evidence in the
investigation into her death
the tributes continued to flow for the
nine-year-old many are reminders of her
innocence the police arrested two men
over two days on suspicion of her murder
one 36 years old the other 33 both have
now been released on bail with the 36
year old record to prison for breaching
the terms of his license after what
appears to be a setback the police
appeal for information was renewed today
merseyside police posted this message on
social media a simple request share this
far and wide to everyone you know and
ask them to share it further still so
that there's no hiding place for anyone
involved in the murder of little olivia
we need names silence is not an option
at hanfield applause for the
nine-year-old in the ninth minute of
liverpool's game against bournemouth
before they went on to win by nine goals
a triumph topped off with this tribute
by their captain
this councillor says here
everyone is hurting
here in the community you know this this
has been
a massive shock it really has and you
know things have started over maybe the
last three weeks but um this is is
it hit everyone with by surprise
it's not just olivia liverpool's morning
free lives lost to gun violence in a
week 28 year old council worker ashley
dale was one of those
her friends and family gathered today
sending a sea of color into the air to
celebrate the life of someone they knew
had so much more to give
if it can happen to ashley
it can happen to anyone and that's the
that's the scariest thing
it doesn't really say too much about
liverpool right now i know a lot of
people
don't want to be here um you know they
want to leave they want to go and go
into other things i know for me
personally i'm not planning on staying
we should have had
many more milestones to come 30th
birthdays babies managers and obviously
she's been taken away from us
as the police try to make progress
they're asking people to keep those who
have been killed in their hearts and
come forward with any information shinki
marike sky news liverpool